[Music]
we're going to see a lot of this over
the years seeing the raiders in person
now a reality for las vegas the nfl
released the preseason schedule
and a home date with ted seahawks is
less than 90 days away john treats
joining us
with the three dates you need to know
before the 2021 regular season
begins that's right the raiders will
roll out their retractable grass fire up
their commemorative flame and unlock
those expensive doors
on august 14th for nfl football from the
very first stadium committee meeting on
the campus of unlv in 2016
las vegas has waited for a seat in the
palace
and now they can mark their calendars 17
regular season games means one less
preseason game the raiders have just one
exhibition date in las vegas but it is
the first and it will be
memorable the seahawks will come to town
in 85 days
for the first friendly tune-up the
raiders will then take their act on the
road
twice in california people are asking in
the work hallways how much do you think
that one preseason ticket will cost can
you put a price on history
it'll likely be more than a car payment
but the tickets are going to go faster
than your car too so it'll be fun